we'll get to explore no man skies
massive galaxies in about a week but one
gamer has already boldly gone where no
man has gone before reddit user Damian
bought a leaked copy of the game for a
very large sum of money and now he says
he's beaten it and he has a lot to say
about the journey we're going to keep
this spoiler free but long story short
Damian claims he's reached the center of
Nome and Sky's galaxy the trip took him
about 30 hours but getting there doesn't
mean he's completely finished the game
there's still plenty of ship upgrading
and planted exploring to be done he
mainly stuck to a direct path to the
center of the galaxy for all the details
you can check out Damien spoiler filled
post on reddit snowman sky officially
launches on ps4 and PC next Tuesday
August ninth so you don't have to wait
that much longer to experience the
journey for yourself developer hello
games has released plenty of vignettes
about the game's many features and you
can check those out on gamespot and for
all the latest from the video game
universe you're already in the right
place
you